do are you one of us who also want to
see the amazing spider-man
the right question i would love to see
the amazing spider-man 3 yes
so wonderful was how andrew was able to
kind of make amends with the characters
and the studio
you know to kind of win the general
public back uh that scene where he saves
zendaya like the fan reactions who saved
who
he saved us right
now
and obviously
oh man brandon davis that guy is always
getting the right answers i don't know
how to slip in the perfect question this
guy is a master subscribe to this man
welcome back to new rock stars is it
fair to say the mvp of spider-man no way
home was andrew garfield i mean tom
holland just fueled the speculation for
another andrew garfield spider-man film
and an interview with the always scoop
score and brandon davis in the phase
zero podcast over at comicbook.com
subscribe to them great folks over there
and thank you so much to them for
getting this great answer out of tom
holland because yeah we do need more of
andrew garfield's heroics after he
rescued zendaya actually we really could
have used him on euphoria last night
because rue rude
this is inside marvel we should say it's
new rockstar's weekly marvel reaction
show no it's not a euphoria after show i
actually wish we had time to do euphoria
after shows
we just don't have time don't have time
to fit it in also it would be impossible
for us to censor all that dick uh
because there's a lot of it on that show
i'm eric voss i'm here with mt mt
thoughts oh man um i need some more
andrew garfield in my life as spider-man
and like
like we got we got all those teasers at
the end of the amazing spider-man 2 they
were promising a whole universe so like
let's get it going marvel let's play
them come on they had plans they're
still there the plans are still there i
mean the work has already been done in
spider-man no way home i would say and
yes we are talking about spider-man
knowing home because it remains the
number one movie in the world it's
breaking all kinds of records it's about
to surpass avatar you know what it is to
surpass avatar in box office revenue so
yeah a lot of you are saying you guys
sure are milking this movie aren't you
well yeah the world is milking this
movie we're following the world's lead
right now you wanna watch us make videos
about [ __ ] moonfall no nobody cares
about moonball
no way home was just a massive event it
changed the mcu in every possible way
including the fact that we everything we
saw you could argue in the tobey mcguire
trilogy the andrew garfield two movies
uh technically over 100 hours of
narrative in the netflix marvel universe
possibly arguably mcu canon now i mean
endgame didn't cross over that much it
crossed over to its own universe we have
several different universes being
crossed over add that to the fact that
we had big purple cracks in the sky full
of cameos we have a crazy memory wipe
spell at the end of the movie that
retconned things maybe we don't really
quite know there's so much coming out of
this movie uh
symbiote goose slipping around
yeah you're going to hear us talk about
this movie for months and years to come
because
right yeah i mean
i mean look there's just still so much
to talk about in this movie we we gotta
still it's gonna take us multiple weeks
to figure this out yeah man and chief
among all those questions is the fact
that sony has miraculously reinvigorated
the franchises of toby and andrew and
now andrew garfield who's about probably
to be an oscar front runner is perfectly
positioned to return to his narrative as
peter parker we want it andrew probably
wants it tom holland definitely wants it
sony has to want it and
we talk about a fourth mt wants
it make mt's birthday dreams come true
it's it's not your birthday your
birthday it's not may but it could be my
birthday now
you can announce it in may and give
empty a birthday surprise exactly well
last week we talked about a fourth toby
film and what would a third andrew
garfield spider-man movie look like
we're gonna discuss that we're also
gonna talk about some big news we just
learned about how the animated into the
spider-verse franchise might connect to
this shared universe how i have no idea
but i'm very excited to think about it
but before we get to all of that huge
announcement this week february 11th you
can see new rockstars live show in
chicago it's going to be just clements
and tommy bechtold philip molina we're
going to mix it up with some fun
surprises that we have never done here
on the new rockstars channel before this
is an event hosted by our partners at
rooster teeth part of their very normal
podcast store we're going to be sharing
the night with the hilarious folks at
the face jam podcast tickets are still
available so click the link in the
description if you live in the chicago
area we would just love love love to
meet you in person all right mt what is
our question this week
well we gotta ask it what would a third
andrew garfield spiderman film look like
eric now empty in a way couldn't you
argue that spider-man no way home was a
third andrew garfield spider-man film i
absolutely did have a solid character
arc in the second half of this movie he
began with freaking rolls being thrown
at him
lowest of the low
no respect for this man couldn't dodge
those rolls nope too fast
even mj and ned considered him maybe
there's a better peter parker out there
they were not impressed by his ability
to climb the ceiling they were like
our peter can do that
yeah right
let's keep let's keep uh swooshing and
see what we find out
he started this movie as peter number
three but he climbed his way up into our
hearts says peter number one i would
argue in our books in my mind when he
and toby maguire peter counsel tom
holland peter about grief andrew
garfield peter said that he never truly
got over gwen's death that he tried to
be the friendly neighborhood spider-man
but at some point he just stopped
pulling his punches he got rageful he
got bitter this was truly a darkest
timeline peter parker this film
screenplay came out recently and
included a great piece of exposition for
andrew garfield peter the moment he
watched tom holland peter and mj
embracing each other the script says
quote on webb versus peter watching them
with a tinge of longing the kind of love
he had and lost and this is what leads
to toby to check in with him asking you
have someone and andrew graciously
doesn't respond no [ __ ] i told
you
[Laughter]
that's right
look at little richard parker jr
vertebrae is broken gonna cry
[Music]
but no this is such a wholesome moment
in reality like toby tells him i
wouldn't give up uh which just feels
like a step toward this guy thinking
like no no all is not lost you know this
isn't just about rescuing this kid from
another dimension we found you yourself
are worthy of redemption uh which we
finally get to see in this final battle
we knew this was coming from the trailer
and it felt so good to see it uh zendaya
mj falling from the scaffolding goblin
swipes tom holland peter away from
catching her and andrew is just right
there to catch her he loses it when he
does she's like so did i eric
we're all like none of us are okay right
now
um in the script i love how the script
uh like describes this moment it says
overwhelmed with emotion web verse peter
nods having just relived the worst
moment of his life when he lost gwen
stacy and the amazing spider-man 2 but
this time he prevailed and i i love that
like throughout the script they they
call these peters by the directors of
this old franchise they call him webb
verse peter raimi vs peter and he calls
out the title of the movie the amazing
spider-man 2. all these things now being
kind of re-legitimized in the eyes of
this story uh in a way that breathes new
life into them
and all this catharsis is coming in with
that pep talk he got from toby telling
him that he is amazing the fact that he
tells the other peters that they feel
like his brothers that he never had that
he loves them even if they didn't say it
back
but this also comes after his moment
with max dillon when andrew kind of
acknowledges the expectation that there
should be a black spider-man and the
script also includes this great
exposition webb vs peter nods there
probably is italicized there meaning
it's that's like andrew garfield's
character's thought in that moment but
it's also just like phrased in this way
to where it feels like the writers of
the script acknowledging yes there is a
miles around spider-man
so as we look ahead to hopefully a third
andrew garfield spider-man film let's
just like wipe the slate clean from
whatever was planned for the next movie
in this continuity and empty you were
hinting at this uh just a reminder to
everyone that sony did have plans for a
sinister six event with dane dehaan as
harry osborne goblin reese iphone's
coming back as lizard paul giamatti
probably going back as rhino and then
vulture and dock and then the sixth
member of the sinister six who's either
gonna be like craving the hunter maybe
mysterio maybe chameleon felicity jones
was rumored to return as felicia hardy
black cat dennis leary said in an
interview years later that there was
some kind of subplot development that uh
they might have planned to resurrect the
dead people in peter's life via cloning
including uncle ben
including gwen stacy
yeah we are we're sure that might have
just been something that was pitched to
him but they pitched it in vegas his
character was dead they're like no we
might bring you back and he's like how
am i gonna come back and they're like oh
you know they're going to clone you he's
probably like i don't get it
it might have been cool we don't know um
but i think the best way to go forward
is just to assume that all to now be
part of andrew garfield peter's past
history like he said he got bitter
rageful stopped pulling his punches
maybe that was just referring to when he
beat to death harry osborne goblin and
all that now is just like a previous
chapter
and then
his inability to get over gwen's death
could have been because of that whole
unnatural cloning experiment that really
reopened the gwen wounds in a way that
caused him to relapse into his grief
maybe he was okay at the end of the
amazing spider-man 2 but then someone
tried to play god defy the laws of
nature try to bring gwen back in this
wrong way and that caused him to go
further and deeper into his grief and uh
and prevent him from truly finishing his
stages of healing um but now thankfully
peter drew if you think of this role for
him as the amazing spider-man 2.5 which
i do i think this is such a great art
for him in this movie um he's really his
best self returning to his home
continuity so three questions i want us
to address empty one will andrew
garfield be the spider-man of sony's
villain universe with venom morbius
craving the hunter now madame webb we've
learned uh will andrew garfield remember
the events of no way home or did dr
strange's spell affect him too and three
that line about the black spider-man
could that be directly setting up andrew
garfield to be the miles morales mentor
in the next movie
so let's let's take these one by one uh
do we want and do we think andrew
garfield is going to be
the the shared spider-man here of this
universe i guess in the way that like
ben affleck batman was the the batman of
like the suicide squad 2016 film who
just kind of showed up foiling villains
in in other corners in other people's
movies you know i feel like this would
be the smartest choice um considering
that you know people really want the
amazing spider-man 3 they really want to
see the continuation of andrew garfield
story but like i just can't think of i
can't stop thinking about that poster in
morbius of of toby mcguire peter parker
and i'm like what is going on here like
why is that there like are we just
having a shared universe so i'm just
thinking like yeah like i don't know
what happened post the spell but like i
i need that poster answered like to some
degree but you see empty i think that
poster is the easiest uh spider-man
reference in morbius to just justify
simply by saying oh it's just fan art
it's just fan it's just some graffiti
artist just had this vision of
spider-man in his head it's not like
it wasn't a direct photographic
recreation of what spider-man looks like
in this universe um because really i
think that's how the set designer
approached it i think the set designer
was like oh we need to have spider-man
being called a murderer in this universe
so let's just get us spider-man we'll
get it from the loading art from the ps4
game and that was just the era the sam
raimi era of spider-man but it wasn't a
particular frame from that movie right
um and it's interesting they called him
a murderer because that could apply to
this version of andrew garfield right
like andrew garfield said he stopped
pulling his punches he could be a
murderous spider-man in that oh my god
that's so true like because like you
there's definitely some type of chance
that andrew garfield definitely murdered
at least one person during those dark
times because yeah we saw in the
original trilogy with tommy aguirre even
though he didn't technically kill his
uncle ben's murderer he he facilitated
the the events that led to his fall
let's be real um and so um and also
andrew garfield wasn't there with toby
mcguire when he stopped the glider it
was just toby mcguire
and
no um i think that it would be great to
for him to be the the main spider-man
and it would be the smartest decision um
but like i just again i still don't
understand the poster in that morbius
trailer what do you think do you think
yeah i i think i think you're speaking
to something that's just like a general
confusion of what sony's intention is
and they are kind of all over the map i
think what seems to be their intent is
that morbius is taking place in the same
universe as venom just the fact that
morbius trailer ended with him
referencing his venom meaning he knows
who it is there's that other line from
al madrigal's character he's like oh
that's the craziest thing that happens
in san francisco like
i think despite the other weird things
showing up in that universe i think they
want that uh to be the same thing
however in the morbius trailer we see
the ozcorp tower it has the same logo
the same building as what it was in the
2014 andrew garfield film so i think
sony is saying that that those universes
are the same they're like we have our
shared universe partnership with marvel
that's the mcu we understand the
difference there but everything else is
taking place in the universe we've
always been in uh i just think the
question is
whether andrew garfield wants to do this
right like the guy is hot right now i
don't know so i want to just sign up
just to do a cameo and some crappy movie
i think
he's gonna want to
like he's a team player of course all
musical theater guys or team players
everyone all these superheroes every
single musical make it a requirement
that they've done a production of a tick
tick boom or oklahoma
uh no i'm kidding but like i think
andrew garfield um i don't know if he'll
want to just do a quick cameo in
something but i would also argue sony
doesn't really need andrew garfield they
could just have a mass spider-man that
they have anyone play in that suit and
just doesn't say anything just kind of
waves and whips away and then that's
that's enough i think for for a cameo
and morbius in the background or
something like true uh but craven the
hunter i i won spider-man in a craven
movie right oh my god hunter and praise
bro i would pay
sony twice the amount of money to see
craven hunt down spider-man like are you
kidding me yeah yeah and my thinking is
we've just gotten these reports of a
madame webb movie like they're they're
having dakota johnson play uh madame
webb we don't know if it's gonna be the
the julie carpenter or the cassandra
webb version of the character but like
i i would hope that you're gonna embrace
the multiversal aspects of madame webb
and have a lot of these spider-man
variants come back right that would be
my hope so i think it's easy just to
imply that andrew garfield is a
spider-man of sony's villain universe
without having to have him make a direct
cameo in every single one of these but i
think that should be kind of the rule
going forward uh i think that's totally
fine i think fans will easily accept
that and i think that's kind of what we
want and i think sony honestly wants
that at the end of the day
there's an argument to be made i'm gonna
sound crazy there's an argument to be
made that like a year from now we all
view andrew garfield as a bigger star
than tom holland nothing against tom
holland i'm just saying uncharted i
don't know how good uncharted is going
to do
where it's a video game movie we'll see
i could do great i could be talking
about my ass that movie could make a
billion dollars we don't know but i'm
just saying like all i'm saying is
andrew garfield is back in on the a-list
he's as big of a star now as he's ever
been so um but a question just kind of a
technical question yeah will andrew
garfield character remember the events
of no way home how did this spell affect
him did it affect the peters of other
reality did he forget that he himself
was spider-man did he forget that that
particular tom holland variant was
spider-man and if that's the case what
does he remember from the final act does
he remember seeing this kid's face does
he remember seeing a masked spider-man
does he remember any of the statue of
liberty stuff um i have a feeling that
only the peter parkers remember the
events of no way home and that everybody
else that knew who peter parker was
across the multiverse just completely
forgot because we remember what wong
says in the movie that the spell travels
the borders of known and unknown
realities so i'm assuming that that
means the space between realities and it
can just go to any reality because it's
that powerful of a spell so i think that
this is sort of sony's way of just
giving a blank slate to every single
spider-man um and just be like hey
anybody who knows doesn't know anymore
and like i feel like that
would um definitely help
propel their stories forward because now
all these peters have to deal with the
same sort of trauma of
my mj doesn't remember me what the heck
like why does like why are we doing that
and like i feel like that would
definitely be in service to mcguire's
story especially because after we leave
in uh spider-man 3 him and mary jane are
not on like the best of terms so like we
do hear that he things do work out for
toby mcguire but like if he lost his
memory of everybody then that would be
such an interesting way if they were to
go like spider-man 4 were out that'd be
interesting but for
andrew garfield back to the actual topic
i feel like sony needed this reset to
happen for andrew garfield in particular
because of that weird plot line where
everybody on
oscorp knew who
peter parker was a spider-man and it was
like really weird like the guys in the
van yeah and it's just like we're
following this kid and like it's part of
the conspiracy yeah i wanted him to get
bitten by a spider maybe yeah yeah so i
just feel like oscorp that whole like
weird oscar they were like let's just
forget that let's just wreck combat this
for everyone forgot and like now he can
just be himself oh that's interesting i
i think
at the
for the most part
other people in other realities
their perceptions of the andrew garfield
and the tope maguire version of
spider-man have not changed like people
who knew still know people don't know
don't know i think the way the the spell
at the end of the movie works is it has
one subject and that is the tom holland
version of peter parker that is the only
person who uh about whom anyone's
memories has been affected um but in
terms of who the spell affects in order
to have that perception of that
character it affects anyone who is in
this reality at the moment the spell was
cast um but it does not affect people
who are peter parker i think
so it's like kind of like a double logic
switcheroo i honestly don't think the
writers have thought about it that hard
i think it's crazy for us to even try to
explain i think the writers just did it
thinking it would be the simplest
approach not realizing how many
loopholes this would create
everybody named peter parker's just like
oh my god everyone forgot i think andrew
garfield and toby maguire need to
remember if you want to pursue a future
with them they need you need to just say
like oh the spell didn't affect me and
they they remember the events
but people in their reality who knew
that they were spider-man uh whether i
think i am okay with whoever at oscorp
still knowing that peter parker is that
richard parker's son of spider-man i
don't because my thing with that movie
is like
it
it had it was just trying to do too much
uh and i rewatched it leading up to no
way home and i think whenever he goes
down to that roosevelt subway station it
just becomes a national treasure it just
feels so weird and disconnected from the
rest of the movie yeah i don't we don't
need that but i think it's okay for
oscorp to be a conspiratorial
organization that planned for peter
parker to be bit i'm i'm okay with that
storyline being pursued i think it's a
little weird it does take away a bit of
peter parker's uh accidental stumbling
in to becoming spider-man um but we
already have that in the other versions
of the character um so like it'd be okay
now to have like mul this doesn't have
to be our one definitive spider-man like
we have other spider-man if that's not
our cup of tea you have other people to
approach um
so i don't know i i i love a spider
universe where oscorp exists at the end
of the day and right now oscorp doesn't
exist in the mcu so i need it to exist
somewhere right like i want to see
odds corp do evil [ __ ] and this is right
that's the oscar's whole thing doing
evil [ __ ] selling weapons come on yeah
so i think at the end of the day uh yeah
i think these peter parker i don't think
they would say that everything that
happened with these peters and other
universes was also erased i don't think
sony would want that to be the case and
i think whatever movie gets made after
that they're gonna clear that up uh and
i think sony would also say i don't
think they if they ever pursued andrew
garfield or tobin mcguire again i don't
think they would have no memory of what
happened i think that would be
a storytelling missed opportunity oh for
sure um
and and speaking of opportunities are
the third question that line about the
black spider-man it really feels like
there's a great opportunity here to have
andrew garfield a character we've
already seen be spider-man in manhattan
now be able to
be a mentor figure to miles morales in
this side of the universe would you
rather see miles morales introduced as
someone in
uh tom holland's universe or in andrew
garfield's universe not to say that
would mean miles miles could never
appear in the mcu obviously
we all want that to be the case we want
miles morales to hang out with hulk and
dr strange and everybody else
but should he be introduced as uh
someone looking up to andrew garfield or
someone looking up to tom holland or
thinking those two guys are bogus and
wanting to do things too
i'm looking up to professor xavier um no
um
i think that you know i i definitely
understand like the reason for the
question because in the comics miles
morales was of course introduced in the
uh 1610 universe rather than the main um
marvel universe so like it would make
sense for a miles morales to pop up in
andrew garfield's universe and then be
introduced to the mcu much like it was
in the comics um so i think andrew
garfield would make a great mentor for
miles morales and like because of that
little moment between um electro and
spider-man um i just feel like that is
the thread that they could go with it's
like all right
there's a they're talking about a black
spider-man we could just go introduce it
in this universe and then like have our
own little
side little project while also doing tom
holland and all that stuff but we also
know that tom holland is really
wanting to pass that title of spider-man
eventually um before he gets 30 or
something like that in his quote
because like he just doesn't want to
hold on to that title of spider-man
forever because he feels like it should
be um something that a younger um and
it's more diverse person should have so
i definitely feel like an mcu spider-man
and again with um the introduction of
aaron davis in um in a spider-man
homecoming as the prowler mile's uncle
it just seems like those seeds are are
definitely lame for us to see a um an
mcu miles morales and i feel like more
people would prefer miles morales just
native to the mcu in general um so
yeah out of those two cases for all
these characters yeah yeah out of those
two possibilities i feel like it's
definitely gonna be the mcu version
however
if we're going to talk about mentors i
say let's do all three spider-man as the
mentors for for miles morales why not
like in this dude i will i honestly just
want to call it the spider-man 4 where
it's for spider-man just mentoring eyes
and like it would just be like three
dads
just
take care of miles i would love that
that would be the best course of action
but what do you think i totally see that
it reminds me of like a live-action
version of into the spider-verse where
you just have like a team of past
experience spider things mentoring miles
morales uh no complaints on that pitch
here's my pitch for how i want this all
to go down i want andrew garfield to be
implied to be the spider-man i
understand if morbius is already wrapped
you know uh and you're just not gonna
fit him in there but to imply maybe
that's already the case you know um but
when craving the hunter when that movie
comes out i want the spider-man that
that craven hunts to be andrew garfield
spider-man i want to see the what that
really means that people in this
universe consider andrew garfield's
character a murderer uh and maybe he did
make a lot of enemies in this world he
is kind of a
a rogue vigilante someone who's gone too
hard and
like everyone has turned on him not just
the way people turn on tom holland's
character at the beginning of no way
home made him kind of a a figure who you
know he was able to get matt murdoch to
get him
to get him uh a pretty good legal deal
out of all this um
but what if someone is like no it's
clear like
you murdered quite a few people was it
justified maybe it was justified use the
force but this guy is
people are mad at him and then you know
somewhat little j jonah jameson whoever
it is hires craven the hunter to go
after him and then maybe that
incapacitates andrew garfield but
through the events of that story in the
same way that like
miles morales is introduced when the
peter parker of that universe dies he
could step up to be the spider-man to
take his place
after that so miles is introduced on the
sony side of things now i know we have
donald glover's character in spider-man
homecoming i honestly think we aren't
going to see that well like i don't know
if donald glover is going to come back
in the mcu he's too big a name i don't
know if that guy wants to play prowler
like
he's a huge name he should you know i
don't think he's interested so i don't
know if they're going to introduce miles
morales in the mcu he's too big of a
title for sony i think they want to
introduce him on their side of things
and andrew garfield is a hot hot
commodity right now to introduce these
two together and then they score a deal
with
with uh marvel to have miles miles show
up in secret wars or some of these other
crossover events then he can join the
universe and they can kind of share him
um but i think
you have an opportunity now to have him
be in the universe of andrew garfield uh
so sony feels like they have more
control over him now that's not to say
they're not going to consult with kevin
feige or the marvel team at all i have a
feeling that the same way that feige and
pascal collaborated to cast tom holland
back in 2014 2015 i think you're going
to see that same kind of collaboration
to cast whoever's going to play miles
morales i think
i hope i hope that sony sees the value
in marvel's insight and their
collaboration
really fasting brilliance through sarah
finn yeah right
so get her in the room have her help you
pick the right the right miles morales
for this um and i think at the end of
the day yeah it's all gonna be part of a
shared universe uh i i think there's
gonna be plenty of opportunities for
these two studios to work together again
to make billions and billions of dollars
uh but i think i think we're gonna start
with with that that would be my hope for
how this all goes and then you have a
madame webb movie that hopefully
introduces all these characters my hope
for madame webb is that like we truly do
get to see a nexus uh moment where
everyone's just staying in the web of
life and destiny and she is
explaining the rules to everyone uh i i
think that's very he's gonna be the nick
fury man but the spider versus the blade
nick fury of that yeah of that section
well we uh want to talk about some ways
the animated into the spider-verse might
be crossing it over into this
live-action world based off of lord and
miller some quotes they said but before
we get to that we want to thank helix
for sponsoring today's episode speaking
of good sleep last thing you want is to
be tossed and turning because you're on
a bum mattress well that's why you've
got to get yourself a helix mattress
helix sleep has a quiz that matches your
body type and your sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you they have
soft medium and firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot even a helix plus mattress
for plus size sleepers i have a helix
mattress i love it the quiz match me
with a medium burn mattress with lumbar
support that sleeps cool the mattress
ships right to your door for free no
need to go to a mattress store just go
to helixsleep.com
insidemarble take their two minute sleep
quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you are going to love it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixleve.com inside
marvel we also want to thank expressvpn
for sponsoring this episode we all
occasionally dabble in the not safer
work parts of the internet you probably
think that as long as you're in
incognito mode everything is fine well
not so fast incognito mode does not hide
your activity my friends it doesn't
matter what mode you use or how many
times you clear your browsing history
your internet service provider can still
see every single website you have ever
visited and that's why when you are at
home you should never go online without
using expressvpn isps in the us can
legally sell your information to ad
companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so your isp
can't see the sites that you visit
expressvpn also keeps all your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available it runs seamlessly
in the background you just tap one
button and you are protected expressvpn
is available on all your devices your
phones computers even your smart tv so
there's no excuse for you to not be
using it protect your online activity
today with the vpn rated number one by
business insider visit our exclusive
link expressvpn.com
marvel and you can get an extra three
months free on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
marvel expressvpn.com marvel to learn
more okay mt the other major spider-man
news we got this week came from an
interview from joshua with his happy sad
confused show this is the same guy who
got that infamous werewolf quote out of
andrew garfield
another brilliant interviewer who can
just get the best quotes out of folks uh
this time he talked with the into the
spider-verse and across the spider-verse
directors phil lord and chris miller or
the producers gods themselves
they really are amazing let's take a
look talk to me i'm so endlessly
fascinated on where we are in spider-man
world because right now there are two
different
there are two different spider-man
multiverse spider-man
franchises at least
or are there
oh
the multiverse is big and wide
and then all things grow it's an
infinite verse i mean
all i'm saying
me as josh
sony the heir to the sony franchise
would not want two different things he
would want it all to cohesively come
together wouldn't it be good
why would you think a multiverse in
which many many things are possible uh
uh that they're not related right that
everything's possible except for this
one thing that everyone wants
wow
wow wow wow wow that is huge pretty big
i don't fully i can't wrap my mind
around how this would work mt let's talk
about it how could the animated miles
morales connect to the live-action
sonyverse and mcu considering that's one
shared universe now are we talking about
who framed roger rabbit type stuff
animation and live action are we talking
about
voices from live action showing up in
this next animated film what do you
think honestly if if anything were to
happen i have this feeling that the mcu
would come to animation because it's
easier to translate live action to
animation versus animation to live
action uh because you know i i just
don't think that you know haley seinfeld
in a blonde wig and i don't think she
could pull off the gwen stacy look as
hayley styles even though she can pull
off anything because she's amazing um
but no i i think that you know we'll
we'll end up seeing
tom holland
at some point during spider-man 4 maybe
or like some point um in the future um
tom holland falling into the shenanigans
of the animated universe and then he's
gonna probably be in in part two um if i
would guess of across the spider verse
um just judging by what they're saying i
have no clue that's not confirmed at all
um but i i honestly think that you know
with with this um success that sony has
like like you like you sort of hit it at
with the whole like sony wanted to do
miles morales might wanted to do miles
miles on their own i think they might
just want to take it to home and be like
all right we're just gonna take make all
the money on our own and just like just
bring them in and like you know just
reap the benefits of our tom hall and
mcu deal uh by just you know having this
story in the animated world be canon um
in the future like tom holland will
reference it in the live action universe
in the future and it's be like oh my god
he talked about miles morales and like
all that stuff so like i think that
that's the smartest route and it's the
route that like kevin feige has to do
the less
least stuff with he's like all right
just take him and then do that and then
he'll come back and like it's easy
how do you think it's going to connect i
don't know yeah i i i think remember
lord and miller did say uh after the
2018 into the spider-verse came out that
they wanted to do a cameo by tom holland
and potentially toby and andrew they
wanted to have them just show up just
pop up kind of as a gag in that movie
and they were told by sony not yet
they didn't say no they said not yet
they said it was too soon and now we
know why now we know why they had plans
to show them in live action and now that
they have the gates are open i think
it's way easier now just to have tom
holland andrew garfield mcguire voice
animated versions of their characters
and across the spiderverse uh we don't
know fully what the story is gonna be
but we know it's gonna be visiting uh
the indian peter parker we know that
it's gonna be of course going back to
the miguel o'hara spider-man's universe
um which means i think we're just going
to see a lot a lot of different
spider-man variants uh in that movie and
of course it's called across the spider
verse for for some reason right
right uh and i think it's just going to
say that you know through the magic of
the web of life and destiny um and i
think
characters just show up through miles
morales's point of view the animated
miles morales shanick moore's miles
morales uh in animated form that's just
like the texture of their reality as
animation but it exists in a
spider-verse alongside a live-action
reality and i think that's why they're
showing us so many different forms of
animation at different frame rates
different uh contouring different
texturing i i think the idea is that uh
like we may see a stop-motion you know
universe uh we could see one where it's
like made with toys we could see one
where it's with 3d animation right like
there's so many different things you can
show
that which show like all different media
that we see on the big screen
is fair game uh and that includes a
reality it's just from miles morales
point of view in his animated world this
is what these spider-man variants look
like uh but he exists in the world now
would this mean that shamiq moore plays
miles morales in
the world's no i think there are other
miles morales who are out there
i don't know schmidt more could be great
in this role uh i don't know i'm just i
think that there's plenty of ways that
they could just easily have these people
exist in the world together and i think
sony's want is to suggest that all these
things are connected because the more
connected they are the more valuable
each corner of this universe is how
likely do you feel that the animated
spider-man could show up in the animated
disney plus side of marvel because we
have that whole universe where like we
have a whole multiverse of animation so
like and we do have um freshman year
coming out in in the future so like do
you think that you know we could have a
crossover with what if or something or
like the what if animation of the mcu to
sort of like be like all right here's
them in the mcu now um i don't know i'm
just thinking about the fascinating
question that's a fascinating question
mt it's really a legal question right
i'd have to take a look at the contracts
but i believe
i don't know how spider-man freshman
year has come about uh i think any time
disney wants to use spider-man and put
spider-man's name in the title
that's a lot of uh legal
coming to terms like there's a lot of
profit sharing off that uh and so
they have to
shell out a ton of money to sony
whenever they want to use spiderman in
anything i think it's likely that miles
could show up in freshman year
uh i think that's if they're already
having a spider-man show on disney plus
that would be the place that he showed
up i don't know if he would show up in
what if because right now it it kind of
ties the hands of the producers of what
if if they have to include spider-man in
a specific way i think that the
producers of what if are like there's uh
thousands of other marvel characters we
could we could show in episodes
and they just got the x-men
and when spider-man showed up in the
zombie episode that was like a very
specific thing right like he
they the suit that he was wearing was
the disneyland version of the spider-man
suit if i'm this is true right yeah so
like there's always like very specific
things and it was tom holland's likeness
it was not tom holland's voice uh so
there's all these specific things i mean
and who knows like we keep seeing these
mixed reports that in the future
disney plus has scored some deals with
sony to feature future spider-man titles
uh on the platform i don't know if that
was referring just to freshman year or
if they have other plans to maybe get
the tom holland spider-man movies
finally on the platform um i don't know
i think sony makes more money to license
these things out to like netflix and to
these other platforms um
but
yeah i think it is
now more likely than it was before
i guess if the question was could
animated miles morales show up i don't
know if it's going to be the exact
version of the into the spider-verse
animated miles morales though i think
it's more likely to be a new version of
animated miles morales just because
those that into the spider-verse
universe is so precious to sony i think
they like the idea that it's connected
but they want to be able to control that
corner of it uh narratively speaking and
keep it in the hands of the producers
the directors the animators who produce
that 2018 movie uh and rather than hand
it over to a creative team that they
didn't necessarily green light you know
it's true and like i think that during
this interview or a recent interview
with the lord miller they they said that
they were um in close contact with
obviously uh jonathan jonathan watts um
they said that they were in close
contact with john watts and like the the
creators on no way home and like to make
sure that they were telling distinctly
different stories um so they don't step
on each other's toes right now yeah so
like they're gonna definitely want to
make sure that their stuff is like
unique and sort of like stands on its
own for the most part yeah
and i think despite the fact that we
want everything to be connected
tangentially there's a real value in
having these things feel texturally
different as we're watching them like
how great was it to go into 2018 into
the spider-verse and have it look
completely different from anything we
had seen in the mcu the reason we're
doing this in an animation is you can
show things that are way harder to show
in live action and just watching this
trailer for across the spider verse the
realities he's flying through the
animation looks beautiful i don't know
if you can pull that off as well in live
action yet i mean i don't know vfx
technology may get better and better and
we could show it it looks great in line
action but right now just animation you
can have the action words show up in
into meal in hindi you know that's so
cool um
you can have uh you can just pull things
off that you wouldn't necessarily get
away with in live action and i would say
that also goes for spider-man freshman
year i think that's gonna feel different
from anything we had seen before and
that might be a good thing no i won't i
just want mcu lebron james to show up in
uh the live action i mean like in the
animated spider-verse for no reason just
do space jam
just for no reason just random lebron
james
that would be a bridge too far you'd
have suddenly have the flintstones and
iron out all the hannah barberas
suddenly would be part of this universe
all the sideline cameos
well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel don't forget to check out
our many great merch options at new
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow mt mastertainment subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcasts i think next week we may be
talking about a multiverse of madness
trailer that drops during the super bowl
we will see
i hope so let's go super bowl we will
see you next week thanks for watching
bye everybody love you guys peace
you